now the deep state they're clearly in
panic mode but also tonight so too are
their best friends in the Democratic
Party now for nearly three years
Pelosi Schumer their radical base they
have relied on nothing other than lies
conspiracy theories the politics of
destruction they've been on a mission
and that is to take down a duly elected
president president Trump at all costs
now they had no plan to improve the
economy
none none to improve the lives of the
Forgotten men and women the people of
this country that make the country great
no solution for immigration no vision
for more peace around the world instead
three long years one big lie conspiracy
theory you know a Roswell New Mexico
level conspiracy but now the gig is up
we now have four separate investigations
that have all cleared President Trump of
the spurious charges leveled against him
in his campaign no collusion fact no
obstruction fact and now with their
collusion hoax dead unburied and
absolutely zero record of accomplishment
from anybody in the Democratic Party all
Democrats there now grasping at straws
and now oh let's go to a fifth
investigation maybe we'll make it an
impeachment threat over what unspecified
phantom crimes that they can't even seem
to describe their little literally
demanding what would be a fifth separate
investigation into Trump and Russia rage
hatred psychosis now govern this new
radical extreme democratic socialist
party so today right before an important
infrastructure meeting planned at the
White House Nancy Pelosi she had plenty
of time to continue the lying and
recklessly accuse the president of a
cover-up by the way while you watch this
think a cover-up of what would you
believe that it's important for the to
follow the facts we believe that no one
is above the law including the President
of the United
sakes and we believe that the President
of the United States is engaged in a
cover-up okay accusing the president of
covering up a crime that never happened
covering up exactly what speaker Pelosi
what is the President of the United
States covering up investigations from
the FBI
Bob Muller House Intel committee
bipartisan Senate panel on the same
Russia collusion lie all cleared the
president and yet speaker Pelosi by the
way she's only speaker and name only she
asked it now capitulated to a radical
base led by the real Speaker of the
House and that of course congresswoman
Alexandria Acacio Cortes and her friends
in the radical left Pelosi of course now
acting on the insane dictates
yes given by freshmen Congress women to
bash our commander-in-chief just minutes
before what was supposed to be a
bipartisan important meeting on meeting
on infrastructure at the White House
president he's done two and a half years
cooperation no executive privilege
encouraged everybody to testify 1.5
million documents even answered Mona's
questions he's done now he is not going
to be a punching bag day in and day out
and today the president rightly fought
back in a huge way he should do it he
did do it and according to reports
president he walked right into his
meeting with Pelosi and Schumer called
them out for their unethical conduct and
end of the meeting and walked into the
Rose Garden where he delivered these
pretty powerful remarks take a look the
whole thing with Russia was a hoax as it
relates to the Trump administration and
myself was a total horrible thing that
happened to our country that I have
Nancy Pelosi go out and say that the
President of the United States engaged
in a cover-up doubt we've had a house
investigation we have Senate
investigations we have investigations
like nobody has ever had before there's
nothing we did nothing wrong I walked
into the room and I told
[Music]
Senator Schumer speaker Pelosi I want to
do infrastructure I want to do it more
than you want to do it I'd be really
good at that that's what I do
but you know what you can't do it under
these circumstances so get these phony
investigations over with yeah it is
beyond sad it's frankly pathetic these
phony investigations sick conspiracy
theories
that's all this Democratic radical
socialist party has Pelosi
she's been speaker now for nearly six
months they've accomplished nothing she
turned down a compromise on daca
compromise for dreamers she refused to
address the crisis at the border said
building walls are immoral she wasn't
saying that in Obama's second term she
blocked any attempt to address the
failures that everybody pays more lost
their doctor oh and by the way they
don't have any choices anymore
Obama care she and a fellow Democrats
they play zero role in what is now the
best economy we have seen in decades it
is roaring America's energy independence
Democrats no role the millions of new
jobs created no role whatsoever 1.7
million jobs available more than people
on unemployment securing the border no
role whatsoever trade deals nothing
they've done nothing and she can't even
show up to a bipartisan infrastructure
meeting without launching a vile attack
against the president first this is not
Pelosi first rodeo though she knows her
impeachment fantasies it's bad politics
it won't work and she is completely and
utterly controlled by the radical
socialist base in her party as I said it
speaker Pelosi in name only
Pelosi doesn't appease Acacio Cortez
congresswoman Omar and others
she knows she's out of leadership and
that's why after today's White House
meeting Pelosi doubled down on dumb and
on these unfounded attacks against the
President and said she'd pray for him
wasn't really respectful of the reason
of that Congress and the White House
working together he just
took a pass in any event I pray for the
President of the United States and I
pray for the United States of America
the fact is in plain sight in the public
domain this president is obstructing
justice and he's engaged in a cover-up
and that could be an impeachable that's
the leader Wow all right on Twitter the
president a special message for Pelosi
writing quote Democratic leadership is
tearing the u.s. apart but I will
continue to set records for the American
people and Nancy thank you so much for
your prayers I know you truly mean it
kind of crack me up
Democrats their friends and the media
mob they spent three long years trying
to con you the American people make no
doubt they lied to you they lied the
entire time this is no longer the party
of a Joe Lieberman even a Tip O'Neill
strong liberal Massachusetts scoop
Jackson instead it is now the party of
radical socialists liars con artists and
conspiracy theorists that's who they are
that's all they own we're the solutions
for the American people and
appropriately enough at one time Savior
Michael avenatti is once again in
serious legal trouble today yes we was
charged with stealing money from stormy
stormy stormy stories book deal he's
also facing separate extortion charges
on 36 other federal indictments for
perjury theft fraud for months by the
way avenatti was begging to come on this
program over and over again and we never
gave him a serious platform he never
deserved it we've looked at him as the
well frankly we kind of saw through him
from the get-go this channel literally
called out his fraud over and over again
by the way we still give him the
presumption of innocence something he'd
never give to justice Cavanaugh but this
wasn't the case on other networks for
over a year the media mob worshipped at
the altar of avenatti giving him hours
and hours of airtime to spew his
fraudulent unchecked accusations and
they were giddy about every interview
remember this I'm doing now by stormy
Daniels lawyer Michael avenatti thanks
for making time storied angels lawyer
Michael avenatti joins us live now Mike
Michael thank you very much for joining
us the attorney for Stephanie Clifford
aka stormy Daniels mr. avenatti welcome
to Meet the Press sir
Michael avenatti yes sir thanks for
being on the show tonight I appreciate
it
Michael thank you so much for being here
with us this morning Michael Abernathy
joins me now good evening Michael
let's bring in Michael avenatti stormy
Daniels attorney of course Michael with
our welcome to you and here to discuss
the stormy Daniels attorney Michael
avenatti Michael it's good to see you
let's first get reaction though from
stormy Daniels attorney Michael avenatti
go go now the people you just saw
promoting avenatti and his claims
they're the same people promoted the
Russian lies and conspiracy theories
against the president every second
minute hour of every day
st. people now calling for this
impeachment over phantom crimes the same
I believers in the Cavanaugh case and
the ones that believe in protecting
Hillary from real obstruction with real
intent and a real underlying crime and
the media mobs reckless bias has never
been more palpable than today it is
clear now more than ever as we said in O
7 and beyond journalism in America it is
dead it is buried we're going to have a
lot more coming up throughout the hour
as I said we have a lot of guests coming
up tonight breaking news we have a big
story to cover the house ranking
Intelligence Committee member Devon unis
in a letter to President Trump the
congressman he is now urging President
Trump to discuss Hillary's dirty Russian
bought and paid for dossier with his
British counterpart writing quote I
respectfully request that you asked
Prime Minister May about the British
government's knowledge of the steel
dossier and whether the British
government took any unilateral actions
based on information provided by steel
at the request of any US departments in
other words it appears the ranking
member of the House in telemedicine to
believe the British government may have
also used the dirty Russian phony lying
dossier Hillary paid for as a basis to
spy on a political campaign so tonight
the question remains did they coordinate
with our own American Intel agencies to
spy on an America
citizen working for the Trump campaign
maybe trying to get them to circumvent
American laws and do things that they
would never be allowed to do just the
question